good morning believe nation I want you
to ignore the little man forget about
the naysayers and the haters and build
something to prove them wrong just like
Michael Dell did if you look at our
story you know at any point in in the
process
you could have gone to conventional you
know experts the fact I remember I won't
name the the person because he's he's
still a extremely well-known author of
famous business books teaches at a very
prominent university you know I showed
up at a conference when the company was
you know three or four years old and you
know he was sort of critiquing our
business and he kind of sell this will
never work
you know and and it was a common
experience I mean went when when we
launched our business in the United
Kingdom
we had about 22 journalists show up and
it was it was sort of funny because
about three or four weeks before we
launched we started actually selling and
the thing was just going like crazy it
was just growing so so fast which is a
good thing because when we had the
launch about 21 of the 22 journalists
said oh this is a horrible idea never
work in the UK it's a completely
American idea and you know don't even
think about coming here you should just
pack your bags and go home
good lucky for me we'd already started
and so hey guys love to entertain some
more questions but I got to go back to
the to the office cuz you know we're
busy taking orders and you know making
computers this is such an important clip
because everybody has a little man in
their life everybody has the person or
group of people who tell them it's not
possible that their dreams cannot happen
and point out all the things that are
wrong with your plan and instead of
giving you encouragement and ways to fix
it they just pound on your your ego and
your self-confidence what if Michael
Dell decided to listen to that purr
sir instead of launching down what if he
decided to listen to those reporters
instead of expanding overseas Michael
Dell didn't listen to them and he became
a billionaire because of it
I remember when I was trying to expand
my youtube channel I went to go see an
expert who told me that the things I was
doing was wrong he told me I didn't
understand how the internet worked and
what if I listened to that guy right
oftentimes a little man isn't expert
it's not just somebody hate on you it's
not an old friend or somebody in your
family who doesn't know anything about
your industry hating on you
those people are easy to brush aside but
sometimes the expert is the person in
the industry right the little man is
that expert what if I listen to him you
guys wouldn't have an spresso in the
morning I wouldn't have nearly as much
fulfillment and excitement and joy and
happiness in my life you've got to
believe in what you're doing you've got
to know that it's gonna work out and
stop listening to the little thank you
guys for watching question of the day
today is who is a little man in your
life I'm curious I want to know who they
are
you don't dimensioned my name but tell
me the story leave it in the comments
below who's your little man thank you so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
tomorrow morning again for another shot
of espresso